razors say that in the blade stealth 13
they have
the world's first gaming ultrabook and
while i've
really enjoyed my time with this tiny
little beast
i'm worried that in their pursuit of
trying to become the jack of all trades
they might end up as the master very few
now it's important to keep in mind that
it's not really fair to put this thing
up against
your traditional gaming laptop it's not
advertised as
a gaming laptop it's an ultrabook it's
meant to be
thin and light and compact and discreet
and
stealthy i guess it's not trying to be
the all-powerful bulky huge
heavy gaming laptops that you see it's
meant to fit
in more of its own middle ground and for
the most part i think it does that
really well the first thing that you're
likely to notice that for
gaming device this thing is pretty small
it's just over half an inch thick
and weighs only 1.4
kilograms the power supply and the cable
weighs just over 600 grams
so you're packing quite a lot of power
in about two kilos now if this was a
parallel universe where we could travel
this is going to be an incredible little
device
to keep on you at all times to throw in
your backpack because it is so small
and light and compact yet very very
powerful
if you take in you know it's square
inches to
the amount of power that it puts out
it's extremely impressive
so packed within this discreet package
you have an 11th gen
intel core i7 1165 g7 quad-core cpu
it features the 13.3 inch 120 hertz
1080p display
its own dedicated nvidia geforce gtx
1650
ti max q gpu 16 gigabytes of dual core
ram
and a 512 gigabyte nvme ssd
now that is something i want to go into
a little bit later
and then for your input outputs you have
two type a usb
3.1 ports two thunderbolt 4 usbc
ports both of which can be used to power
the device if you want to
switch either side and a 3.5 millimeter
headphone
and microphone jack it's hd webcam also
features windows hello
so that's less time on fiddly login
screens and more time jumping right into
your games
the touchpad is microsoft precision
glass
now i don't know how much you're going
to use the touchpad for gaming
i can definitely say that as far as
touchpads go this is one that i
ate the least i've tried it out for
strategy games like crusader kings
played boulder's gate with it
and it works pretty well i don't think
any point was i like
oh yeah i'd rather this over a mouse the
keyboard also felt great for pretty much
any game that i was playing on it
features a full-sized left-hand side
shift key which is really nice as well
and it has just enough feedback for
every keystroke
not so loud that you're going to annoy
anyone in the office just loud enough
just enough tactile feel can actually
make you feel like you're pressing the
key
again this fits in a nice middle ground
that it felt good for gaming it felt
good for word processing editing videos
daily use it take a little bit me to get
used to
but for a couple days it does feel
like a really great keyboard especially
for a device this size
when it comes to the speakers that was
also an area that i was extremely
impressed with
it has probably some of the best
speakers i've heard on a laptop and
definitely the best speakers i've heard
on an
ultrabook it uses four stereo speakers
with thx's spatial audio and all that
together creates something that's
really good for when you're consuming
media and which i assume
a lot of people would use this for but
surprisingly good
when it comes to playing games
gun firing call of duty explosions in
doom
all sounded again surprisingly good
coming out of a device this thin
now what i'm sure you want to know is
how the thing performs playing all these
games
after all calls itself the world's first
gaming ultrabook
does it live up to that g word in its
title
well while playing doom eternal on high
i was averaging
about 70 to 80 frames per second
sometimes maxing out at 112 frames
i never felt a single dip or real low
point
or stutter when it came to the frame
rate and on the 120 hertz display
it was of course looking fantastic
oldest gate 3 however is a strange run
because
it is obviously in early access so some
of the performance bugs might need to be
squashed but that being said i was still
getting an extremely
steady 60 to 70 frames a second
star wars squadrons was a little more
hit and miss i was able to get
70-ish frames on high but i was feeling
a fair few stutters when the game was
getting a little cluttered
or action-packed a lot of enemies on the
screen
a lot of debris i did start to feel the
slowdown now when i really started to
feel a performance hit it was when i was
playing
call of duty modern warfare now this
game is plastered all over
the pages for the razer blade stealth on
the razer website
so i was assuming that i was going to
get some pretty good numbers
but it didn't perform quite as well as i
wanted it to
and for the most part i was getting
anywhere from 60 to 65 frames per second
in multiplayer lobbies but again even on
the low to medium settings
when the action gets really intense the
frames do
start to crash but for modern warfare in
particular it suffers from
really good frames from up to 90 fps
when it's a little quieter
and a little less action-packed all the
way down to the 20s when things get a
bit more intense
massive number of explosions and things
like white phosphorus would
absolutely tank the frame rate even on
low to medium settings
but for the other 90 of the time it ran
really well
and again being able to play games like
this on a device this small
is still a great experience
now one of my main gripes with this
device is also connected to call of duty
modern warfare
and that is the size of the ssd with
only 512 gigabytes
that's not a lot when you consider the
asking price of these things anything
from a grand and a half to two grand
i think they'd be able to squeeze in a
bigger hard drive especially when
in 2020 512 gigabytes doesn't get you
that far when it comes to gaming
and if you're going to be using this for
video processing a daily driver
if you want to play more than one game
on it at a time
you're gonna be struggling and the fact
that modern warfare is all over the site
as well
and at the moment of recording modern
warfare is a
250 gigabyte game if you want the full
package
i found myself struggling for space now
you can of course
you wanted to you have an external hard
drive and keep your steam library on
that
that's fine i was running doom eternal
off an external ssd
because i was running short on space
doing all the tests
but i don't think you should have to for
the price if it was a terabyte
i'd be absolutely fine this would be a
non-issue the fact
that more than half almost
is taken up by one game a game that they
advertise alongside
of the machine that was honestly a
little bit of a sticking point like
of course you can swap out a solid state
again already dropping
a fair few bucks on this thing now i
don't think the idea of carrying around
a
steam library in your backpack is going
to be a deal breaker
especially if this is not going to be
your primary machine but
bloody hell it would have been a nice to
have you know
have my gaming device not struggling for
space because i wanted to play
more than two games now when it comes to
the aspects of playing games there is a
question of how long you're actually
able to do that for
just on battery power alone now i was
getting anywhere from
50 minutes to an hour and a half
obviously depending on
the game and the performance which isn't
a lot
but at the same time more than i
expected for a device
so small normal use like word processing
and watching videos it goes from about
six to eight hours
again broadly fine in the world of
ultrabooks
not as much you're gonna get with a
full-blown laptop
but still there's gonna be few cases
that you're gonna find yourself eight
hours away
from a power supply but don't plan on
taking this thing
on a long train journey or a plane
and getting the whole journey worth of
gaming out of it
something else i noticed while using
this thing as well is that while playing
games the thing will
get pretty hot and hand-in-hand with
that
a little noisy not as hot and not as
noisy as you might expect
and not nearly as hot and noisy some
devices that i've used in the past
but definitely enough to take notice now
just before i jump back to my
opening statement and close this video
off i wanted to point out
something that i only just noticed and
this thing is a
fingerprint magnet it's it's real
stylish i
i like the the chassis and i think it
looks super cool
i polished this thing at the start of
this video just before i hit record
and it is already an absolute mess
so i've come full circle back to my
opening statement
the whole jack of all trades thing this
sits
in the middle somewhere somewhere
between the ultra light word processor
web browser
photoshop machine and a intense
mobile gaming rig but
it doesn't do any of them perfectly
this is something that if you want
something very light and portable and
you want
more power when it comes to like video
editing
photoshop if you want something for just
emails word processing on the go
and you want some gaming on top of that
then i think this is the device for you
if you do want to save some weight and
you don't want to carry
a heavy gaming laptop because
those things can weigh a hefty amount
and i think this is going to fit a niche
for you
but unfortunately i think that's what it
is it is a niche
it does a lot of the things it offers
really great and often surprisingly well
especially like i said when it's so
small
thin and light having a
fast display in there its own dedicated
gpu
and getting the performance that i got
out of a lot of games was again
surprising and i can see me
using this as my on the go machine
because it does offer that power
or my daily work day but can also
run most of the games i want
without that much of a graphical hit to
you know keep that performance up in
conclusion this thing does
a lot of things really really great
when it comes to its storage that's
really my main gripe it would have been
nice
to see a terabyte in this thing
especially
compared to its fairly high price point
but if you're in the niche that wants
something very light so delivers really
impressive performance
then this device might just be the one
for you but let me know your thoughts in
the comments section down below
if you were building your own gaming
ultrabook what would you
want out of it and of course in addition
to that you want any more
hardware reviews tech news or gaming
previews then make sure you stay tuned
to gamespot
[Music]
you